السلمون الأطلسي على مدار
حياته سوف يسافر من مسقط رأسه
والأنهار التي تتدفق إلى شمال
المحيط الأطلسي
شمالًا حتى الأراضي الخضراء والعودة
مرة أخرى لوضع بيضها ،
إنها رحلة ملحمية ولكن
الجري المهيب للسلمون قد يصبح شيئًا  في
الماضي
في الولايات المتحدة ، كان سمك السلمون الأطلسي مهددًا
بالتلوث الفيدرالي ، وقد أثرت المبيدات الحشرية
بشدة على موطن النهر ،
ولكن هناك شيء واحد أكثر من أي شيء
آخر دمر أعدادهم ،
كانت السدود هي القضية الأساسية ولا تزال القضية
الأساسية
، ويمكن أن تكون تلك السدود صغيرة
مثل  كنقطة
عبور عند معبر طريق
لا يستطيع السلمون النهوض منه ، وعلى مدار
10 إلى 15 عامًا ، يمكننا رؤية هذه الأسماك
تذهب من الكوكب إلى الأبد
إذا لم ننتقل إلى العمل ، يدير دواين شاو مفرخات
اتحاد السلمون الشرقي
في  ماين
على مدى 200 عام في الولايات المتحدة ،
كانت هناك محاولات
للحفاظ على
استعادة وإدامة السلمون الأطلسي ،
كان هناك العديد من
الإخفاقات التي اعتمدناها
التقنية التي طورها بيتر جراي
، واتضح أنها تعمل بشكل
جيد بالنسبة لنا ، كان
بيتر جراي يدير مفرخًا على
نهر تاين في نورثمبرلاند في المملكة المتحدة
عندما بدأ النهر كان
ملوثًا بشدة ،
وكان تعداد السلمون اللعين يكاد يكون معدومًا تقريبًا
منهجية بيتر الفريدة.  جنبًا إلى جنب مع
استعادة الموائل والحد من التلوث ،
ساهمت في واحدة من أكبر
قصص نجاح استعادة السلمون في أوروبا ،
طور بيتر تقنية بمرور الوقت قامت
بتجنيس طرق التفريخ بحيث
تمت معاملة الأسماك
مثل الأسماك البرية وبدرجة أقل كمخلوق مستزرع
بناءً على منهجية بيتر.
تحاول مفرخات داوني تربية
بيض السلمون الخاص بهم في ظروف تتناسب مع
بيئتهم الطبيعية
بما في ذلك استخدام خزانات مياه النهر ذات القاع
الداكن ووضع المفرخات على
النهر الأصلي ، ولكن هناك جدلًا قويًا
حول المفرخات
مع العديد من المرافق التي يعتقد أنها تضر أكثر
مما تنفع  سمك
السلمون يقول العلم أن الكراهية حقيقة  d الأسماك
ليست قوية مثل الأسماك البرية ، ولكن على
سبيل المثال في الولايات المتحدة
حيث تكون المخزونات البرية من السلمون منخفضة للغاية ،
فإن الطريقة الوحيدة لتكون حافزًا
لاستعادة تلك المخزونات هي الحصول على
مفرخات السلمون ، لذا فهي بمثابة مخزون متوازن
لاستعادة  ثم تتوقف المخزونات في
وقت
يمكنك فيه ترك الطبيعة تأخذ
مجراها ولا تتلف تلك المخزونات
وراثيًا ،
فنحن نبقي مدير المفرخ بعيدًا
عن الصورة قدر الإمكان
بقصد إغلاق المفرخ فعليًا في
أقرب وقت ممكن.
إذا لم نفعل شيئًا ، فإن هذه الأسماك
ستتحرك بسرعة نحو الانقراض
يتم قياس نجاحها من خلال إيجاد
بيض السلمون البالغ العائد إلى
النهر وربط جيناتها بتلك
الخاصة بأسماك المفرخات التي
نراها 20 ضعف
معدل العائد الذي  يعطينا الأمل
في أنه في الواقع يمكننا تغيير الأمور
بسرعة أكبر ، فإن
حفظ السلمون يفعل أكثر بكثير من
إنقاذ الأنواع ،
فهو عبارة عن أنواع مظلة تحمي
السلمون وتساعد جميع أشكال الحياة في موطنها
السلمون.  هو المؤشر الطبيعي النهائي
لصحة البيئة المائية
في كل من المياه العذبة والبحر
إذا كان سمك السلمون يعمل بكثرة ، فإن
الأمور على ما يرام.